what's been the biggest change you've
seen
in my lifetime
since you were a kid
so many of them but what really sticks
is uh the assassination and imprisonment
of all my mentors Heroes
as I was a young man through the Civil
Rights witnessing that
and then still we and uh the racism and
the Discrimination Jim Crow is still
alive is just more sophisticated
you know Rick became more Humane because
of the technology
and now I could say I witnessed the
civil rights movement in the 60s
when he first televised it and I saw
like this brother
was going to vote
in law enforcement wouldn't let them
vote and they pushed them with the billy
clubs and stuff back down the steps and
one fella came up behind them and kicked
him
and uh that visual never left
my math
and he was an older gentleman and these
were some young fellas his counterparts
and the sheriff and whoever the law
enforcement was there
which I'm really cool pushing it alone
he was about himself just trying to
register to vote
and the sad part about it when it got to
the bottom of the stairs
these are white kids
kicking a black man in his ass
and um they're Visual and he was just
trying to vote
you know and I was like 12 11 12 or
something like that and the first time I
really experienced
it is disparities disparities between
The Haves and the have-nots and us into
them my father used to deliver Liquor on
the north side of Chicago
late 50s early 60s and on Saturdays I
used to ride with them ever since school
Care Highland Park and um
we was on 51st and federal before the
projects and the Dan Ryan so it was
considered Shack town
and and
we used to hate my mothers that he
walked on a pot belly cold stove we
didn't have no inside Plumbing we had a
toilet but it was like an outhouse in
the house because we had no
pipes and this and that but back to the
North Shore
we had to go through the you know the
re-entry to deliver
and the first time I went into one of
the homes
I had to be like eight or nine years old
and that was the first time
I sort of disparaged between us and them
I didn't even know that type of stuff
them people had in their house existed
we own a pot-bellied Coastal the Heat
number 10 round tub the mode number 10
is the bathed in and
my mother and father had 16 of us
and uh my oldest brother thank God he's
79. good health moving handsome fellow
still good been with his wife over 40
years
his kids grandkids great grandkids
it's good compared to wherever we
started from in fact my whole family but
uh
he was the first boy and I was the
second
but we're at the six years apart so
while he was doing the paper routes you
know asking people from jewels and high
school you know carry groceries and this
and then on Saturdays so I used to have
to do the mopping and taking out the
garbage in this and that
but as a kid I saw the disparity and I
didn't understand why
that they doing this and and we can't
pay a light bill
we don't have no gas and nothing and
that turned me
and uh
and watching what was they televising on
TV and what I was reading
a black revolutionary soul brother was
born
and ever since then uh
I've been trying to find a way to even
scale but I have more days behind me
than in front of me
and uh
I don't know
you know I'm not gonna say it's hopeless
because as long as we have breath in our
body we have hope
so I'm I'm just
I'm just
I'm living on a hope for a change do you
feel like things are getting better for
the race issue than they were then yes
until we got to uh the 21st century
technology with the media
and we get instant
news we get
stuff that go viral and uh
I still see the racism
privilege
and US them
and uh
back in the 60s when they are signed the
Civil Rights Movement
exposed to this on tours but then they
see we had a civil rights we could vote
but then in the 60 they introduced the
drugs the black Vacation movies the
Donald gong books
and my generation was the generation
supposed to take us to the next level
but we was influenced by what we've seen
because we never seen a black man
come out on top of a white man so that
was Jim Brown our hero and super flat
and all that so
they glorified the drugs the pimp the
street life
and at the 10 age we was impressive
because we haven't been nowhere out the
neighborhood and we thinking that's the
world and then we see the parent players
Hustlers and gangsters in the
neighborhood they style it and profiling
and then we look at our parents
struggling
the scale
and we're very impressive just like this
generation behind us two three with the
rap songs that gangster rap and [__]
get my money and all this and
and look at the what they didn't done to
our young Brothers
where they think
well when we was kids like I said in the
60s
we was in Florence about street life
but now that the world has opened up
and they still doing the same thing with
this generation they've been tricked
they've been bamboozled and they like us
their eyes was off the prize
and we wanted naturally what they had
and how we gonna get it you can't go to
the bank
you know
and then like I said the first time I've
ever seen a black man come out on top of
a white man was on a movie that was my
hero
so instead of Martin Malcolm
and Marcus them Our Heroes who took our
eyes off the prize now super flat of mac
and all that stuff because to us
they had money
and it was living a type of life that I
seen on North Shore
and naturally I want some of that
and and but how
when this you know deck of stuff
stacked against us
but
like with my education only went through
the Chicago Board of Education to
today's grade
I got my eighth grade diploma in St
Charles Juvenile Facility
I got my GED in the county jail
I got into
introduced to college with Malcolm X
goes back in the 60s when I was 18. I
started GED program for the brothers and
sisters that was a street organization
wise
and uh
that didn't last because they didn't
want that and when I
when I was 22 years old I was sentenced
to 10 to 20 years in the penitentiary
and I didn't know at the time that I had
to bull that on my back because Chicago
defendant at the time was a black one to
the newspaper
and they had put me and Larry in the
society column saying that we was the
next up-and-coming Black leaders Larry
Hoover Hoover yeah
and uh
we that was about when it was 1920 and
by the time we was 22 years old he had
200 years and I had 20.
and I didn't know that that was designed
but I thank God
that they didn't do us like they did
Fred Hampton senior the chairman how
they assassinated him in his bed
with his fiance next to him pregnant
with Fred Hampton Junior and by the
grace of God they survived
but Fred did it and I thank God because
the way my generation especially behind
the Martin Luther King's ride in 69 if
they would have did that to Larry
or Jeff and our generation in Chicago
would have never been the same
you know and we were trying to elevate
ourselves from burn baby burn to learn
baby learn but sometimes
violence become the last resort
and you can't find a better
peaceful man deny I promote One Love
and by the time I was 18 years old I had
been shot for that time trying to
promote one little and uh the Vice Lords
and the Cobra didn't take County to be
bringing an organization from the south
side
to the west side and lay it down in Cape
Town
and uh yeah they
kind of shot me off the corner a couple
of times you know and I survived how did
you guys start the Gangster Disciples
well let's go back before let me give
you a little history
I met Larry we was eight years old we
the same age
and Larry had a studying problem
and you know we was in playing around
athletic and all that old stuff
and he was my little buddy
so when he get excited he go to studying
so here come me I'm moving out the way
and
there I go that's how I became
unofficial spokesman for the
organization and there I used to say
everybody had a divorce and use it I
ain't shut up yet in over 60 years you
know that's I sometimes wonder do we
think
he shouldn't have said it did to me you
know but it worked out but uh yeah we
started
being friends at eight years old back in
1959 because at the time he was living
around 47th and uh Forestville and I'm
on 51st and federal and the Dan Ryan and
all that coming through so they
displaced us between 59th which was a
divided line divide out to 74 which was
another Roundup and a broader line was
from Racine to the west to like Cottage
Grove at the time to the East and that's
where Daley put us now the Dan Ryan
supposed had started going through
Bridgeport
and so that was going to displace him
and his hierarchy in his homes and stuff
so this was Mayor Daley May the first
one yeah so what he did he changed from
going through Bridgeport and swooped it
around through our communities and
displaced us which
is the norm in America
you know and then two as I got older I
realized the ones that was fortunate to
be property owners
they cheated them
gave them peanuts
and really nothing compared to the
market the real estate market back then
and I seen that happen again with the
United Center
they displaced all their folks took
their property and promised that they
was going to put them back in the
community and this and that but it
replaced the Chicago Stadium
when they've built the new stadium yeah
they displaced all them black
folks and they took their little
property
didn't do nothing for them but when you
is in profits like that and here they
come with a few thousand
you know
and then they come to find out later
they got us again you know
what would you say was the
impetus to start the Gangster Disciples
well we was black orientated Community
Based organization we was falling behind
the Black Panther Martin Luther King and
all the lit right
but the generation of us with the
disciples King David was designed for
spots in Inglewood because it was so
concentrated and we were the generation
under them so you know we wanted to do
our own thing every generation with
their own style swag and so forth but
they wasn't having it but what they
didn't realize they was older than us
their parents and they in the 40s
migrated from the south
but we grew up in the city from kids so
we had that Bond
and our thing was one for all and all
for one
so when they came to you know
call himself going on we got to be the
same when we were Supreme Gents
because we thought we was cool and you
know we dressing and this and that they
weren't having that they're gonna make
us so from Supreme Gents
the way we protected ourselves in our
Hood it turned to
Supreme gangsters
now that wasn't our name we were Supreme
since Caruso social club we dancing and
styling and profiling
but David them over us so violence was
not part of the no concept never
no I'm telling you man Luther Malcolm oh
we had that gorilla gangster in us to
survive but we considered ourselves
gentlemen games we was for the community
our Center was based on the same thing
with the Black Panthers and and every
other black organization before we had
our own centers and we had our own
programs we know we fed folks and had
our own teachers and you know we
introduced a lot of I was introduced
through the Black Panther to black
history
because when I come up if you call me
black this is like calling you know
saying your mama
or that that proverbial
on your shoulder
and then
do the Civil Rights Movement even
entertain us Curtis Mayfield James Brown
all the
Temptation smoking
but James Brown was the most powerful
say it loud
I'm Black and I'm Proud
Stokely Carmichael what kind of power we
want Black Power
Fred Hampton
you could kill the Revolutionary but you
can't kill
your killer revolution could calculate
Revolution
I know
I'm standing on some mighty shoulders
and that's why
I want to have to be strong
because I know the generation under me
I'm gonna stand on my shoulders and I
can't be wobbly or hesitant or weak
yeah we gotta be strong
you know like I said as a teenager
I saw them start assassinating prison
all my heroes and mentors and teachers
and I can see back going to the north
side and Seoul them and that's how we
living
I knew it wasn't right
and then when I like to see what the
Chicago boy of Education school system
even I started school in 1955 right
behind the Board of Education
and I was supposed to have been that bad
but equal I'm still reading out of books
right spot wrong
dick growing giant all this old and then
they had a book A Little Black [__] I
can't stand
they had a book a little black symbol
I'm about first second grade had him in
a grass skirt red big old lips are bone
through his nose and they had a big old
kettle pot boiling
and the story went
that
they didn't put no person in the pot but
they insinuated because we supposed to
make caterpillars and our little soups
will be eating
white folks and all this stuff and and
uh little black symbol was at the kettle
and all of a sudden the tiger come up
started chasing Little Black [__]
around the pot and he was running so
fast
well the yellow and black line melted
into margarine butter or whatever and
now we go next page little black symbols
sitting up there with big teeth big lips
a bone and all this
stuff grinning
that's what they was teaching me and
right today I hate
that they still in me that Pledge of
Allegiance no I do not have pledge no
allegiance to America in fact I
denounced my citizenship
but you know how it's just radical you
know how they go I still got a social
security number and uh President Biden
sent me a Kool-Aid check once a month
you know so
you did some time early
what was that for
ah well they said attempt murder
and guns and all lit but they was on
some BS I didn't know I had that Target
on my back as a kid you know so
that's what put me on the path to the
New Concept and growth and development
as far as Thanksgiving is concerned
because I realized
when I got to
that's I got 10 to 20 years for attempt
murder I couldn't find out that's the
most
under the law of the 69 1969 Lord that
they could have gave me so I could have
went in there and told that little
feather glass just to kiss my black ass
and I still really couldn't get no more
than 20 years but I didn't paid these
suckers because at the time we was under
impression you could they was you could
buy your time until you know the great
Lord come out and they bust them judges
and lawyers for you know getting payoffs
and what did Larry get 200 years for
well let me tell you something about
Larry Larry is about I ain't no sucker
so you think I'll take a back seat to a
sucker
Larry a hell of a dude but
that
that street life
he'll probably we all product of our
environment but Larry so much so
his mother used to be a bartender by me
or whatever right so when we come home
from school as a kid she go to work and
and Larry the oldest and he had two
brothers and a sister under him
and we'll go in his bedroom we'll give
the kids a nickel to dab leave us alone
and we're going to bedroom but
the bedroom overlooked the guys and gals
Lounge the parking lot
so we'll sit and cut the light out and
we listened to the parent players
Hustlers and the hookers for years
we was teeny we still before we was in
degree so eight and five WE 12 13 years
old so this is roughly what decade
it's like a 64-65
so every day when his mama leaves we
come up there and we go in this bedroom
cut the light out and we'll sit there
and we'll listen
and we'll listen and then behind his
house when we're on his back porch or in
his backyard the York Hotel sitting on
the corner of 69th and Ashland so while
we back there we see The Pimps and the
hookers taking any tricks up through the
back to the hotel so we standing down
there kicking it with them
and he called himself you know but he
did because I'm still here so some of
the things they told me I violated as a
young man because I was still you know
young full of tolerant foolish but it
carried me right to uh you know to the
day
so naturally
with the black petition
movies
the introduction of drugs into the
community
and them down or gone movies horse on
black pimp and all this
garbage we impressive and they knew that
it was designed for us to feel
because Diego said the biggest threat to
America in America's real life
is the unification of the black man
and you see from the boat back then
Tourette today is still working we can't
figure out a way to unite they don't
want us to unite
no I don't know in my lifetime but
that's my goal in life I have two I want
to see us United not just my growth and
development but all young brothers and
sisters unite and that's that
that giant we've been trying to wake for
you the last 40 50 years because we know
how powerful that is and once we work
that job we gonna be a power to be
reckoned with what do you think Society
needs or what do you think
the black community needs
to do that and I want to see a hill I
want to say leave us alone
leave us alone through history you saw
the progress we made with nothing we
always make something out of nothing
y'all ain't gonna say y'all personally
but they gave us
the garbage to eat and you see now
we're white they love soul food
but it was chitlins what the
can't even spell that [__] let alone
smell it
Goods hog balls some pig balls
greens
all these messes but we
now the best food in the world
best food in the world
yeah what do you think the black
community needs to to rise up
leave us alone
through history we the only race in
America that they bombed us from the
[__] air they dropped bombs on us
and look Wall Street
the rest of them had a every time we
take a step or two forward here they
come
they burn us out they murder us around
us all like with my father and he not
the only one when he came back for world
one with the double piece Peace With
Victory bro peaceful Victor here
Texas when you re-entering he still had
his uniform on proud we didn't want and
stuff
he went into the uh
cab station
and uh
first white person told me in uniform we
just won
first person he saw was coming apart
told him the [__] interest is in the
back
me and Larry had to register
in 1969 we turned 18 because they had to
draft the Vietnam War was going on
no way
and then Muhammad Ali didn't already
told them
ain't no brown skin people on this side
of the world ever called him [__]
they're not his enemy
Yola
why am I gonna go around the world and
kill brown poop brown people the father
y'all Virginia and you know wherever
they go they bring disease destruction
and everything else with them
in every other race that I ever studied
was peace loving people and as far as my
black race
if we was what they tried to say we were
when being the white people on earth
the bombs that you referred to who they
dropped in Philadelphia
and they had a black male good they
dropped it on this organization that
everybody had last name Africa
and uh they wanted them out in
Philadelphia they wanted them out
and they resisted and they had kids
Eric he was going to build a new Bond
and then when he tried to tried to send
the women and the kids out and they were
shooting it
some of them you know survived and then
the sister Africa that survived they
gave her 20 years or some old dumb stuff
you know
yeah
yeah with the black race need from day
one even before they bought us here
leave us alone
they just
you know
like I tell my family my sons and
grandkids
they here so we have to learn how to
coexist
mute honorable respectable do your job
you know do it like my daddy said he's
just a sweet sleeper be the best sleep
just sweeper in the world
but then how can you be the great street
sweeper
for every time you clean up out of spite
and hatred a person coming along in
front of you and throw some [__] on the
ground in front of you
and they act like they dare you
not to clean it up but you got to clean
it up because you have a family
you clean it up because they say you're
a boy but you know you're a man
you know and as far as being human do
you realize
how we have to suppress human emotions
just to get by
say it and going back to the
organization yeah
uh before we were Supreme gangsters at
11 years old when we met Didi
he was a cobra from the projects
and uh he was a couple years old but he
was very impressive because
he had to process as a teenager
TaylorMade clothes jewelry and Larry was
very impressive with that type of life
you know like I say I know how many
hours we spent together and others
looking out their bedroom window but how
many hours when we were near he was
still looking and learning
and uh
he got caught up
yeah we all together you know and uh
I often wonder just think if that wind
was the parking lot to some high
education
you know
just think if that window that parking
lot was the parking lot of a college
even a high school
who knows who knows
you know just like Larry he went to the
ninth grade
and uh the Chicago public school system
and uh first day of school he got shot
in the ass by Highsmith a little Long
Street some disciples you know
and uh that was the end of his public
school education
but he's caught his degree today on the
growth and development
you know but his 200 years was for
murder I assume yeah conspiracy uh needy
he's rapping
was convicted of being an actual shooter
but
some of the folks testified less
especially Larry lovers you know we were
childhood friends testified that Larry
that's all they need he wanted to
testify I said Larry Gator orders I mean
why him and did he wound up with two
hundred years but we should have seen
writing on the wall because DD made
parole
and he was just she was yeah did he but
did he had that gift for the Galvin you
know a little yeah so he made parole
and uh
under the New Concept Larry still
sitting there with these 200 years and
we didn't made that change from old to
the new okay and we even got organized
we didn't got legit and blah blah we
spivi
I made parole well I introduced the
world
to the New Concept October 1981 I
appointed Larry
the chairman we're quite nice I'm gonna
Point myself to co-chair man
and uh
put the first Board of uh
directors board members together induced
you know 16 laws the concepts they've
tied to do this people oh Little Miss
and uh
after a while it was working like I said
I went home you know
January
of 1982.
so Dee robertus was the director of
Illinois State Penitentiary me and him
was cool so for six months he will allow
me to come in and uh you know visit last
when I
ever wanted to but then after he went
from the director of the penitentiary
Governor Thompson and moved hell to be
the director of the tollway so I guess
it is time you know to steal
s and I lost I've never been back into
another Penitentiary institution they
won't allow me I can't
correspond I can't get phone calls and
stuff from Larry it was nobody
and now he never
been convictive actually physically
killing nobody
but they give them 200 years
and uh and A New Concept in the 80s
doing in programs we put together and on
the streets in and out we stopped all
that raping we stopped all that stabbing
all that violence against the police and
blah blah we spit it and it came down to
the wardens them in Illinois State
Penitentiary they said okay cool do what
you have to do but don't escape
but
we gangsters you know someone would like
Sinners made Escape or two you know but
uh
yeah
did the basic
idea behind the Gangster Disciples get
off track over the years
yeah which like I say I went home
and uh January and I've been whispering
in Larry Hills since we was kids
now we don't have that after six months
I got off the road
I organized growth and development
introduced A New Concept to the streets
but after six months I'm off parole I
got married July 29 got off the road
July 28th and I headed for California
August the first I had to go to school
because one of my main
six points was education and here it is
I got
a 8th grade education now we got a ninth
grade so even though we were self-taught
I still had to go to school because we
lead by example how can I make a law to
see if you're 21 and under without a GED
a high school diploma is mandatory for
you to go to school now we'll take all
your basic needs you know nice clothes
gym shoes for visits and we'd smoke we
take care of that you get high and we
will take you know we we took it just go
to school
and one thing I'm proud of under the lit
classes were mandatory is that 20 30
years later Brothers come and introduced
me to their family and they say well I
want you to meet like this fellow I was
telling you about I was a teenager when
I went into the system and you know you
didn't heard about the candy bar on the
bed and you know I'm all lit and he said
didn't have to worry about that he just
concentrated on school and so many of
them even up to Masters and they didn't
realize that they would be taught and
educated because miseducation didn't
want us they wanted us to just have a
strong body and a weak man
we made that transition now we got a
strong man and a strong body
and they still trying to
knock us for that we just want to be
left alone we don't that integration and
all that just leave us alone because
through history you see
they talking about the book you know
grab your bootstrap we ain't had no damn
boots all right now here we gonna grab
come up with that man please we didn't
even have no boots but we made a way out
of no way we made something out of
nothing we always have and then right
today I'm still learning and growing and
through the mass communication new in
real time and this and that and all over
the world
majority of the stuff in this room you
know who invented that
yeah but I keep telling these young
brothers and sisters do you think a big
old fat redneck gonna sit up on his
porch and worry himself on trying to
make them brothers and sisters that's in
their cotton field work a little easier
they loaded a little light no but
because they said we was property so
every dream thought that I have
everywhere that I see out of my mouth
anything I do they own it
so you think they're gonna give me
credit even for the simple street light
we invented the stop light you know they
couldn't
this technology with the iPhones eat
phones and all that mess it comes from a
black man
when he was talking about going to the
moon and stuff them sisters was the one
that put that together where they was
able to act like they've been to the
Moon
I ain't sure about that [__] but I know
they want to find another planet that
could sustain life like on Earth
but we going because they need us so a
few of us gonna go I don't know if I'm
gonna make the cut but I know a few good
young brothers and sisters they going
because they need us
and that's it but they still want to
control us and it's the same way no them
people ain't sitting on no damn poor
sipping no mint Jules and got a brother
fan in them in the summer Mississippi
hot summer and he's sitting up there
worried about Old Joe or Willie George
in the field somewhere under that hot
ass son
picking cotton he gonna make the his
load easier but Willie George and Bobo
and JoJo them come out of come up with a
deal invention to make their work and
when they induced it to this the old
lazy son of a gun
he took it
that was his we property
and can you imagine
your mother and father
love each other they're humans they love
each other we had them emotions
and I'm your master I like your wife
your girl
hey [__]
go get her
and you land next to her what can you do
you got to watch your woman
walk out that door in the middle of the
night and you know that man gonna do
some perverted [__] to her
cause the white women weren't gonna let
them do that to them
can you imagine what that brother had to
go through
and that sister can you imagine when she
came back the hurt and shame
can you imagine
I'm your master I call
your kid one day and I just sold them
off to some place you don't know where
when
we human can you imagine what they do to
a person but they say we animals we die
about we this and that we devils where
we learn it from
we peace love and people because like I
say
the pier ones
when they first came here and
experienced that first winner
the Indians and the blacks should have
let their ass die they shouldn't have
showed them how to survive a winner how
to eat through the winter and you see
what they did
we just want to be left alone you know
we had civilization we had kings and
queens we had everything
until they came
you know I'm a naturally improved black
but
I know a man's heart
and we wouldn't be where we are now
without that Aid in the system one of
them
I had the Pontiac case
in 1970 for the Pontiac ride
you know this is the riot in the Pontiac
Illinois yeah back in 19 July 22nd 1970
when three officers got killed the three
got messed up and the police got burned
down
and they all day me and Larry the
conspiracy they admit they know we ain't
touching nobody we ain't burnt none but
they say it couldn't have happened
without organizing it or not say so so
they gave us a conspiracy they figured
it could get us that way if if any of
his other brothers got convicted under
the conspiracy law they was going to
convict us and by we already convicted
felons that was automatically light
sentence or death sentence
but Governor Thompson his cronies is
like Trump privilege
they just knew
but the unestimated US they had us
listed as function illiterates and we
went along with it but we knew better
that's why we beat that case and me and
Larry we could not only beat it for
ourselves with the conspiracy that means
we had to beat it for other uh 14
Brothers they was guilty or not
and I knew if we had that convicted they
was going to put us in the hole
somewhere for years or what were the
conditions in that prison when it
happened deplorable
anytime
you have two brothers within a week hang
themselves some ain't right need to make
a change and quite naturally they knew
the way the conditions were they knew
you could only just push your brother so
far they knew he was going to rebuild
against it so what they did they went
and got Pinkney a black man that were
retired from the Army
and made him the ward
they knew it was going to happen but
they didn't care it was about the money
all the educational programs was gone
this law said and we supported their
singular sales we supposed to have
access to a law library none of that my
first demonstration and worked and stuff
and food strike was because we didn't
have a law Liberia
my first
shut this [__] down
and then they finally conceded gave us
a law library which was a bloom closet
from the TV called it was some more
antique [__] with a couple of shells
but we kept pushing and read today in
Pontiac there's a brand new building in
the high school that uh have a 21st
century Law Library
I'm proud of that
and I'm uh like this year 2023 was the
best year under growth and development
we had more folks graduating than ever
before
that will be full and that's our first
law is education
when I was uh let's see when I was 17 18
with Malcolm X College with Dr hurts I
started the GED program for the street
organization
it didn't last long because it was
positive so you know they didn't find it
no more and so that's when uh we started
on Elite classes
I have met oh I really don't want to
mention them people because they use
this every politician
every prominent Realm leroys
the Temptation said Stealing In The Name
Of The Lord
and uh yeah I met a bunch of them
Stokely and H1 Brown Bobby seeds
everybody back in the 60s and 70s
I met them and met with them I had like
I said it was my mentors and heroes I
met them through the Garfield
organization which was uh a community
organization on the west side of Chicago
and doing the Martin Luther King rides
Doug Andrews which was the president and
um curly Reed and talk his last name was
brown but he was a tall brother we used
to call the Thomas best name Brown they
was indicted from citing to Riot
now y'all just killed Martin Luther King
Jr now you're gonna take our leaders
from the west side
and charging with the conspiracy for
burning the west side down
but Sammy Davis Jr a bunch of uh Oscar
Brown brunch prominent entertainers and
lawyers in this and that came to him and
Sammy Davis Jr put up over 500 000 for
their bond
you hung up mostly on the west side of
Chicago or the South Side I'm from
Inglewood you're from the South Side yes
I'm from I'm from Chicago but when I was
16 years old and shared
and now at the time the welfare
department had and they could keep you
to use 21.
so by me coming from the south side and
we fighting disciples in the black storm
ranges and anything else because we that
new generation in the Navy
wanted us
so
my parole in order for me to get a
parole I was trying to get out of state
Pro to Detroit
but my cousin found in the street like
killed somebody
so
they said by me never living on the west
side of Chicago about this if my family
would move
from the south side to the west side I
could get paroled before
you know uh at the time like I said you
commissioned kept you to use 21.
so they made their sacrifice and moved
to the West Side never
been over there but
I knew the brothers from the juvenile
systems all the way through school
because they sent me to a dismantry
school Mosley you know for bad boys but
I never was bad I was just inquisitive
you know and uh what they say this stuff
adhc is the most you know how you gonna
tell me
one plus one is two okay cool I figured
that [__] out in five minutes but the
rest of them got 20 more minutes how am
I gonna sit there and be quiet
ain't gonna happen so I'm a bad boy and
I they even put me then had a yellow
school bus though I probably been on it
but they had me in the in the basement
in the Boiler Room
with the mentally challenged and you
know
and one had to go to the bathroom we all
had to go holding hands and all this
mess and uh believe it or not
I had a teacher you know you hear about
teachers you know actually you know what
you want to do when you grow up in this
oh I'm gonna be a police and family you
know typical stuff so I don't know what
I told her but that little fat ugly ass
lady told me don't
put my sights on that in other words you
could you know look at you could be a
janitor you know that type of stuff
yeah Chicago is south side and West
sides are very violent
the violence lots of crime lots of
violence
people are getting killed everybody
trying to survive
nothing trying to get something from
nothing
that's what it is where's the youth
centers remember we had YMCAs and all
that Archie Moore Boxing Club you know
we had field houses in the in in they
cut all that out all the money is going
to Wars
ain't no more Community program just
like name K-Town because of that Tiff
money they talking about what they gonna
build over there I've been in two
meetings in the same [__] they saying
with the same [__] we heard in 69 and it
still got bacon Lots the promises was
empty promise them just like them vacant
Lots
and the same thing now the agree to
bring this Tiffany already sitting at
the time of what they gonna build here
what are you gonna do here excuse me sir
what about the youth
ain't nobody mention no youth programs
ain't nobody actually mentioned nothing
about no after school programs they
didn't took even you know basketball
it's a black man sport how can you take
the rims out of the playgrounds and the
parks in our community now you got
Brothers shooting basketball in a little
milk crate
that's why they so deadly but you notice
too with the NBA the sports period the
blacks
majority of them come from different
countries
a black man in America to get in sports
you got to be exceptional good now
because they didn't open it up to to the
world
football you could be
like the MVP
you know he ain't even America he comes
from some other place but that's what
they do just like with Muhammad Ali and
Joe frazing them in the 60 70 they try
to look for a Great White Hope
and now if you notice how
it then changed in sports
if you got to be light-skinned or mixed
not from the inner city because they say
we violated and this and that and you
notice Curry
Tatum all of them is mixed
and they've been diluting our blood
since the 60s in the 60s they introduced
all these brothers to these different
white girls and Asians and this and that
so they marry them have babies so the
wealth that they accumulated it don't
come back to us when she leave them or
kill them
the money go to them
to that side of the family look at
Michael Jordan
he left Juanita
childhood sweetheart mothers kids for
some form than that
so look at Tiger Woods
I don't like Kanye I don't like common
we protected them in the city what did
they do Kanye still ass took his money
to them Kardashians where the youth
centers I thought when they raid I
thought when them folks
uh mother dad
oh that was a good opportunity to put a
youth center name in after them
especially their mothers educators
and just stay
we could have just the money that they
make we could have youth centers for the
kids in every major city really never
you know because you see the government
the power to be not going to do it they
don't care what Michael Jackson They
Don't Care About Us
and they try to contain it just like
when the young brothers and sisters
start hitting them stores on a
Magnificent Mile and going up north
carjacking and all that
now they ain't laughing at us
because it's everywhere and what you
think it's just could fit so many I'm in
the ghetto
or wrong with no air condition so we
gonna Branch out
like I did I even got to the point by
the time I was 13 I broke in my father's
boss house
I didn't make it all the way through
because he had that old school
pigeon-ass dog making noise but they
didn't bust me at the house but me
buying a black man off Buckingham and uh
Marine Drive
and the sun going down I'm the only
little black dude out there so quite
naturally I was the one trying to break
in these people house
yes it was me you and no matter them two
detectives they tried every trick in the
book to make me confess you go on all
night we do this we do it but they
didn't know my dad big Ike was sitting
outside
ain't no jail it's worse than had to
confront that man and I hadn't tried to
break in this man's house you think I'm
gonna confess and as a kid that's my
first law when I wrote the laws for the
organization silence and secrecy
thousands of secrecy
and it works that's why I'm sitting here
doing this with you now
and we all have secrets of the heart
and I got
a [__] graveyard in mine
you know not only just the secrets all
the brothers and sisters are the laws
not just natural by the hands of the law
and uh
the state
representatives it's just like now we
trying to put a little pressure
on the government and uh Department of
Corrections you know we got C numbers in
Illinois just alone from the 70s they're
still doing time the brothers 50 60 70
years old
what good is your house in them
Independence oh that's right businessmen
on penitentiaries got stocking
penitentiaries and a businessman in the
business to do what make [__] money
right how can I make money with the
penitentiary is empty oh
change the sentencing laws that the our
counterparts
profit from in fact like I said I was
sentenced on a 1960 law and thank God
they couldn't give me no more than 20
years under their law
But Here Come Larry 200 years get the
and and you saw the numbers they've been
giving out
you didn't met a bunch of brothers and
sisters through what you do they've been
in that 20 30 40 years old little crazy
mess but because businessmen
have stock
and influence can you imagine the money
I got if I just had a contract to sell
soap
and then to back in the 80s when they
were doing that farm 80 with foreclosing
all them farms and all this and that and
them Hillbillies came together had them
concerts raising money in this and it
bailed them out
you know we still waiting on uh
it ain't coming ain't nobody gonna build
it so but just leave us alone
I mean but you see the the lack of good
role models in in the inner cities yeah
well I roll my own you see lack of
Education
yeah how are we gonna fix that it's just
like
I go to the schools
you mean to tell me it's not enough
intelligent black men and women to be
teachers to teach our own
and I'm you teaching me some [__] about
Little Black [__]
and then in the 1954 Brown versus Board
of Education they said it's going to be
segregated but equal but fair right
never
was fair it ain't fair today and then
just just like the moves we made
during the Civil Rights Movement they
didn't took him back
you know affirmative action
I'm white and I'm qualified to go to
school would you letting this brother in
and we should sing but he get in because
of affirmative action now I'm being
discriminated against
so when the 60s politician that was with
the Civil Rights Johnson and all themed
and died off you see what happened to
affirmative action is gone
and we don't need it now but it's the
same we always say sir
if
me and my counterparts start at the same
land on the same condition I'm gonna
smoke his ass every time
and I know that but you think they gonna
play fair no
no the stack it's a dick is already
stacked against me
see and we just can't be good
we got to be better
you know I can't just uh
go in there and say I'm a basketball
player in the Pro
I can shoot free throws I can do a layup
I can do a jump shot but now
introduction of uh Dr J with that shot
fade and out of bound and he did I said
oh Lord did he come Michael Jackson oh
Lord they playing a bird around now
but mugs in Split Wheels gave us under
six feet a little hope you know and uh
they made it to the NBA made it to the
hall of fame and they inspired a lot of
young brothers and sisters
but like I said we just can't be
mediocre good
and uh even though I know I could beat
him at the starting line I'ma lose I'm
really gonna lose
and you see what they've been done like
I see it's all our mentors
my heroes and stuff when I was growing
up
and like Martin how can you do that man
like that and he promoted love and peace
and no matter what you did to them you
always turn to cheat but Malcolm said
[__] that I mean with two of these
[__] already been training them
all my life
and you see what they did to him and
then it's sad they put that on them
brothers for killing assassinating
Malcolm 40 years later they admit that
they didn't do it give them a few
thousand dollars and kicked their ass
right back out in the streets just like
with with all
my Childhood Buddy and me too that's why
I could never go to Mississippi even
though my family is from there we could
never go back to Mississippi because
what they did to Emmett tills and we was
born in the city so we don't know
nothing about
move over I'm like man can you imagine
I'm in some [__]
white person coming down there I gotta
get off the sidewalk and take man see we
didn't know nothing about that we didn't
come over so they couldn't uh after
immature we couldn't go back down so
but what kind of person could do that to
a kid
and then on her dying bed she admitted
she was there when they took Emma Till
off his uh grandfather's house and she
was there when he and they did that
stuff to him
and just like this uh black FBI agent he
knew what the FBI did and it was part of
killing Malcolm
but they had threatened him and his
family if he said anything but on his
death bed he told the truth
of what the uh plotted to kill you know
FBI had a hand and killing Malcolm X
you know and it's the same weight
how he did this with the syphilis and
all that
after that Generation Dolls the Next
Generation to ensure their career make a
move
they exposed this stuff
about crack cocaine in the uh oh my God
80s
we're compared to crack cocaine to what
they doing now with this Fentanyl
a new comparison
you know the crack was kind of targeted
towards the black community it's
everything you know the white folks even
admitted
so let's shoot in a dark community and
these will be the Italian gangsters and
[__]
and they said sell it to the donkey but
they never expected their kids
who's going to get a hold of that [__]
just like I'm from Cape Town and uh they
named not Expressway
that's not especially the Herron Highway
because to sit right there next to the
Eisenhower Expressway and all the
suburbs and so who you think we ain't
got no money what do you think these
people prayers and hustle's getting all
this money from and and in the same way
the the prostitutes
crack became knee pimp no more pimps but
they still doing their thing and be
caused them perverts be coming from the
suburbs with them dollars so you know
whatever it takes to get them dollars
they're gonna do that perverted stuff
because they know they can't go home in
the suburbs and do that today
girlfriends and wives and all that other
stuff and uh we all freaks you know
we're young men and [__] yeah we all
freaks and [__] but some of us is just a
little freakier
and on the borderline of some illegal
pedophiles and all that type of mess
what do you uh see for the future of the
black community in America
oh
it's going to take a minute but we're
gonna overcome
you know they gonna
look up one day
and realize just leave him alone
you know like I say all of uh my
counterparts
have a heart because if they didn't we
wouldn't be where we said today the same
way with the Pontiac case that's why
Larry took off
from black next disciple Nation
to GD and he said none ever
before the G and nothing after the D
because he knew
it took all nationalities all people
from all walks of life in the private
sector legal section and everything to
ensure
that we had a fair Shake on that Pontiac
case
and uh everybody all nationalities and
races came and was part of our Pontiac
Brothers support Coalition defense fund
stirring committee and all that and uh
here I see today because of them
yeah so it ain't no we opened an
organization up to all Races
and uh
some of my brothers sisters are gonna
like this even to the gays
and y'all just like football basketball
players that's coming out that's gay
yeah we got gay
board members
it ain't about your sexuality it's about
your men mentality
and I'd rather have some of my gay
brothers and sisters than some of you
with muscles
some of you popping out but do crossword
puzzles play dominoes some exercise your
mind that's a [__] muscle
you know I had a problem trying to put
the laws together about the exercise
program yeah they say yeah oh you silly
[__] yeah you need that size
cause if you got a strong body you're
gonna have a what
strong man it works you know I've been
really cool I've been called Old type of
Lies punks [__] and all that [__]
since I didn't made myself public to
this Facebook but on the reason I made
myself public
because I have been living amongst the
shadows and I was cool I had retired
from the organization when I was 40
years old and when I wrote the laws I
put I lost stage at 35 you could retain
good status and then I put it free
enterprise because I knew I was going to
have business and get money and ain't
one of the [__] come knocking on
my dude talking about cutting me in and
cut it out of what an old organization
if anything the organization owed me and
I'm gonna say this now me and Larry
never traded money
drugs closed none of that always had my
own
and he had his own same way he had his
organization screamed against the next
steps on the South Side I had my
organization on the western North Side
the same way we came there we had the
alliance even though we was as one
disciples still did that thing and the
gangster still did this thing until it
was you know time to come together on
some political business or some
Community affair
yeah but uh
I always been the man behind the man I'm
comfortable with that because I'm
ensuring my ability and um what I do and
what I
no Plus
I had a mother and father in the
household and 16 kids so by the time I
was like 9 10 it had to be about six
seven of us in the house and that what
took me in uh to the streets too because
I have nine sisters and all them stew
pigeons you know so I'd be doing stuff
they didn't tell my mom and father so I
had to keep going farther and farther
away from home and uh I grew up in the
disciples neighborhood the Royal
disciples on 66 and Sangamon and the
headquarters of centers on 64th and
Sangamon and I went to school with them
and come up with them but because of my
nine sisters
family first you know you can't go with
my sister
because I mean you could grow with them
but I just don't [__] with you cause a
family first and we don't play putting
no hands on nobody and I thank God all
nine of my sisters were the type of
women
because I'm their brother
but you yeah I tell hey no you don't
tell like [__] because if you called me
one time if I come and I holler at this
sucker and that night or a day or two
you back with them don't ever call me no
more you're in that sucker just I hope
y'all have a long healthy and a happy
life but don't call even though you my
sister but you know I'm still there
family first but I thank God that I
never had no problems with the different
organizations in the streets when it
came to my uh
family because at a young age I let it
be known
what is it that attracts a young man to
being in a gang family
it's a new family
for a kid that comes from you know
that's why in the early days
organization it was families
you know because
blood don't make family
you know you might start off this family
but uh if more black men stuck around
and raise their their children well see
we did
until the 60s when they start with this
whale Fest stuff and they start in order
for you to get away for you have to name
somebody as the daddy
now they gonna make him a criminal he's
scared to go to work because he's making
minimum wage now they're gonna take that
little [__] from him he's still trying
to maintain and the most embarrassing
thing I've ever seen my father done
these people welfare people because they
was bringing peanut butter and powdered
milk and all that stuff
and somebody said these people was
coming and I seen my daddy a man
get up they're trying to hide the little
regular ass radio they're trying to hide
old broken ass toaster because we don't
supposed to have that stuff and here
come these people gonna go through your
house to see if you get this and that
and you don't supposed to be no man now
because if it was a man that it was
gonna cut off that peanut butter and
powdered milk stuff and we was dependent
on that
yeah they've been doing this
from day one you know just like me and
you this first time we ever met if time
we ever talked but we cool because when
I meet a person I don't care who they
are you get a hundred points now you
could add or lose points but
I'm not gonna let you get past 70.
because if you lose 30 [__] points
that means we're gonna wind up trying to
kill each other in a minute so it's best
for me that's it I always have a point
system like me and you got 100 points so
far you still got a hundred you know I
started to drop one of your points
yesterday when we were talking the phone
when you said what gang I was in
and uh you corrected me yeah oh no I
mean correct I check you earlier because
I'm 72. I'll be 73 in November I ain't
never been in no game what are the games
disciples that's not that's not a new
gang until Jagger Hoover said we was a
game and they just opened the door
because the Black Panthers my mouth uh
SLA all them different you know black
organizations was on the Move what did
you call it an organization yeah I think
part of organization all my life yeah
another game
never again
no they said Hoover and uh you know
Nixon back in CC was a game and then
that's why I don't go with titles with
nicknames and all that dog and bear and
Killer really and all that [__] because
they try to live up to that in fact I
did a thesis when I'm in college on
nicknames and that's why I'm just height
I've been called bird and
Spike and all type of kings and I'm Ill
and I didn't say but I prefer just like
you know like Larry I'm just it I.T I'm
just it he called me it when you don't
like me yes [__]
yeah I've been here a long time
I just hate the way uh
I hate the way they did that man
and just think
the best education we ever had was
independentary
and I do my best thinking in the GLC or
hospital bed and believe me I spent time
in both of them
and uh like I said my best education was
independent even though I had to do
three years on death row and
oh Lord you know and like people be
saying why y'all get together every time
I've been paying attention to equals
that's our life them brothers I did 10
Years brother then 20 30 40 year what
else we gonna talk about when we get
together
stock market
you know or what's that [__] Housewives
of Atlanta or Hollywood or something man
please you know yeah but back to this
organization because I want to say that
to my brothers and sisters you know yeah
we started oh as a community-based
organization and by the 60s introduction
to drugs and that black petitions Donald
Jones all the immense we took our house
to pray but it's still Nation time
we could still do this
we could still wake that giant up you
all don't realize you that giant look
what we did for hair washing care most
Bob even Obama on the election that man
ever lost was when he went against
Reynolds the Black Panther cause he one
of us
on the election they ever lost and why
do you think Jesse Jackson Obama's them
come to Chicago to get off their
political agenda in their career
because they know we'll make it happen
we made it happen we were the first
black politicians in the United States
but
they treat them they tricked us
he checked us built more penitentiaries
instead of schools
and speaking of schools is just like now
with the Ukraine is another ethical
group
in order to get to the schools that they
closed in our communities and the senior
citizen building they opened them up for
them
Link cards the rent page the station for
clothes and all this [__] and in order
for them to get there in our community
had to go past homeless people
homeless camps
and then too
even the Mexicans
they're letting them in illegally or
whatever because they're getting paid
off them because these cartel money
y'all know it ain't just in my community
your community is all over the United
States with that Cartier money you see
they've been building and rehabbing all
these old buildings and that that our
grandparents Greek family used to own
they that fenced up all their property
the vacant Lots around them they got new
cars and all this [__] all of a sudden
where do you get there from
oh okay that's that card to your money
and we was the biggest consumers for 40
[__] years how can I be mad at you
I'm not mad I'm just like in the 80s
when uh Harold Washington was running
for office that's when uh
the Latina put across this came in the
system Gutierrez and all them
and now
we uplifted them and ride on our hotel
this and that
you think they mess with us or not no
you know the last 20 years you ain't
seen no Latino organization hook up with
a black organization
but we like the rest of them Jesse
Jackson and I don't know
oh rage fry I've gone forever
they was cool with us when they first
got here
you know
oh they loved us because we was they
Army we was delays arms it was the
introduction to the community but as
soon as they got a foothold and got a
few grants or whatever and got a few uh
not angle City upper middle class but
compared to where we was at we're
consider them a little upper middle
class all of a sudden we gang bangers
and [__] again [__] you
all my life they used us but I'm not mad
at them because Heidi living now in the
position they had we put them there but
you think I could go somewhere until
Jackson's kids and [__] I need some
money there
to pay off rent not no mortgage just
don't [__] with me they know my name
they know my background
but I'm a gang banger when they get to a
certain level
yeah they've been using us but uh I'm
still proud
because they're in a position we made
first mayors
Carlos LeBron first
Obama
and uh speaking Obama you're a [__]
excuse me he ain't the president no more
oh that's right he's a citizen yeah
because what we've done for you you
could have you gave us an impression you
was gonna help us
you didn't help us you hurted us you had
like Trump in the restaurant before them
when they graded two minutes for the
good election what they do they pardon
all their cronies and their buddies and
stuff you had opportunity man you
spoiled a bit from Chicago we did what
we had to do to put you in that position
and then you had a chance to help Larry
to help us
yeah you like the rest of them
said I was going to be nice but some
[__] like my mama said some
[__] just make you curse
um you could edit you know everybody you
know you can do what you had to do I'm
sorry but uh before we get back to my uh
the organization yeah I'm uh co-founder
of the black supreme gangsters I'm
co-founder black Gangster Disciples I'm
uh
co-founded against the disciple my
original Pontiac brother
and uh proud of my work I'm a coach
chairman the retired code chairman of
growth and development but I am the
historian
and uh
it does my heart good like I said when a
young brother and sister come tell me
because you're an organization that's
where I'm at today only thing I hate is
that we've been around over 50 years so
that means we got Brothers in their 70s
and 80s they're still alive
and we got brothers and sisters here
working we do when you go through just
your daily life in a day you might not
realize it but you be in contact
with brothers and sisters from the
organization but because of the stigma
of what we supposed to be they can't
come out and say because of this or
that'll cause growth development I'm
this and that and I wish y'all would
especially the ones that's retired I
understand your position in your
community your jobs or your church and
this and that but them young Brothers
need to know them young sisters need to
know your testimony where you come from
where your growth and what it took you
oh one more thing under 21st century
vote you notice 2024 election is very
important to us
and we need y'all to register the vote
and participate in the political
organization man we need that Larry
wouldn't be and countless and facing
others wouldn't be political prisoners
because we would have had folks in
office that could have made a change
them unjustly and illegal laws
all right are you good all right thank
you very much thank you very interesting
talk we're not finished I'm gonna come
back you know that